well let's jump to this uh big news
ladies and gentlemen it is a historic
day today
the latest quinnipiac poll came out
showing joe biden's approval ratings at
31
when you add this to the latest
aggregate numbers joe biden's approval
rating right now
in our at the real clear politics
average is 36.8
add in the 31 percent and it drops down
to 36.2
it is a historic day because donald
trump's lowest point was 37.1
that's right
joe biden or is it 30 it's 37.0 sorry i
thought it was 0.1 37 is the lowest
point
joe biden's approval rating right now in
aggregate all of the polls combined is
lower than the lowest point trump ever
experienced in his presidency
this means objectively
historical record
joe biden is to the american people
a worse president than trump wow now i
think the thing about trump is i
actually think trump was one of the best
presidents we've had
you look at the economic indicators
in 2018 when uh he when when democrats
won a bunch of seats
really great economy
jim cramer of all people best numbers of
our lives a lot of good things from
donald trump now you can talk about
decorum fine joe biden across the board
inability to speak no decorum sniffing
children no decorum i will take trump
being a potty mouth and i'll say yeah
yeah yeah yeah but then joe biden sniffs
kids then he destroys the economy he
presides over one of the worst economies
in the history of this country record
inflation record soaring gas prices hype
it's just food shortages are coming
war in eastern europe the surrender of
afghanistan
no question even with donald trump
according to pew only receiving around
five percent positive coverage
he still is now objectively
paulie has pulled better than biden
isn't that something that has got to go
unreal and it's only been
he's got to be impeached he does he
needs to be impeached do you think
you'll be able to impeach him when you
guys win in november i think it's
unforgivable to not impeach him
that's how i feel and i think i think
the american people feel this way and i
think it's imp so i believe in
accountability i you know i think if
someone is doing a bad job or they're
intentionally doing a bad job or they're
not fit for the job you have to fire
them and you have to replace them with
someone that can do a better job and
right now we are in a crisis and i'm
going to go off because they impeached
trump twice and what did trump do for us
the abraham accords historic amazing
peace in the middle east coming what did
he do in peace in the whole world he he
met with kim jong-un and he was mocked
for it and he entered enemy territory
with no security detail one of the most
tremendous things i've seen a president
do in my lifetime and with having family
going back to uh my i believe my great
my maybe my great grandfather
was our great i think my great
grandfather he actually was uh uh from
the north
there was no north of the time
so the country splits and i actually got
to go and visit seoul and see like you
know learn you know try and see like
where my family come from what cities
are they from you know having a family
that came from outside of the us it's a
really interesting thing then i hear
donald trump
he's like i want peace i want to end
this conflict i'm like how amazing would
that be and he crosses the dmz
walks into enemy territory
after all the threats and all the fear
and all the saber rattling they could
have just taken him right there and held
him hostage in anything and they didn't
they didn't do it trump was tremendously
brave for doing that trump had done such
great things on foreign policy he was
getting our troops out of the middle
east he was setting a timeline for
getting out of afghanistan joe biden
screwed that up they impeached him twice
and he did some of the greatest things
i've ever seen as someone who is just
livid over the lives of obama and his
foreign policy to see the tremendous
foreign policy of donald trump that's
right the domestic policy was incredible
as well bringing back manufacturing it's
a great economy but oh i can admit it i
didn't like the way he his attitude but
that didn't matter in the long run yeah
school choice opposing critical race
theory and government contracting good
foreign policy this is a guy who needed
another term and he needs another one
now i uh i thought the worst thing that
was gonna happen to me was becoming pals
with marjorie the worst thing is tim
making me like trump for five minutes
look i think
that that north korea stuff i've never
heard phrase like that and i was like
that's like that's kind of badass it is
and i was i was so angry when they were
like he's pawning up to dictators and
i'm like that's what i heard they could
have killed him yeah he went to nor he
went there and have you seen the videos
of the north korean soldiers trying to
steal the south korean soldiers or the
people trying to flee north korea
getting shot and killed by the north
korean soldiers that's right and donald
trump was like let me walk in here yeah
dude dennis rodman at least looks like
he can take them physically trump
couldn't even run away if they wanted to
go i was i almost cried when i saw him
do it was amazing i was just thinking to
myself like an american president
foregoing security
standing next to enemy soldiers we are
still at war the war never ended and i
was just like wow man yo someone tweeted
me that youtube video and then also put
like the 24 theme song over it and i'll
watch that tonight it's a meme they did
the meme they did kim jong-un has a
skateboard yeah he's like he's like
gesturing
are you serious this is great it's
really good you know he also moved the
american embassy to jerusalem yeah i
don't know that was i thought that was
incredible i really did it was
incredible he pulled us out of that iran
deal
which which the biden administration is
trying to get back into it right now
it's like everything we it's really
obama's third term right it's obama's
third term and joe biden has no idea
what's going on the abraham accords
that planes would be flying from israel
over over uh islamic countries that
commerce would start and what i heard
from the former anti-war left supposedly
the current one is they go yeah well
everyone knows they're all secretly
working together anyway and i was like
are you kidding you couldn't fly from
one country to the other you couldn't
enter one country if you had a stamp
from israel now you can now you can
that's right i'm just you know donald
trump tried getting our troops out of i
think syria was and the the officials
lied about how many troops were in there
because the war machine will not even
even listen to the president and what
happens when biden gets in he botches
and surrenders afghanistan burns it
burns everything to the ground
let me tell you something tim this is
why they hate
president trump
because he wasn't controlled by the
state department and why is it that uh
vladimir putin didn't invade ukraine why
why the conflict had simmered down under
donald trump
it's because donald trump was actually
lowering tensions globally it's
remarkable to think he created
relationships with people like vladimir
putin with kim jong-un he created
relationships and that created peace but
they want the war
they love the war the
military-industrial complex they can't
have donald trump
yeah i've been voting no on this garbage
ever since it started no they want it
and i've been amazed i'm shocked by it
remember when it's not saving anyone's
life it's killing more people trump
fired 59 tomahawk missiles into syria
me uh i get mad a bunch of the populist
right people are like like what is he
doing
and then the media is like is this
trump's truly presidential moment yeah
that's how they see the world isn't it
well it's it's it's something to behold
but what's happening in ukraine
should severely concern everyone it
really should and i'll tell you why
it's we don't belong there we're
neglecting our own border we're
neglecting our own people our our
economy is falling apart inflation's out
of control
democrats are literally destroying
energy fossil fuel industries they want
to completely wipe them out
and it will kill people we have we we
have become a great nation based on
fossil fuels we have we have air
conditioning we have we have heat in the
winter time don't you use air
conditioning against me oh yeah i know i
know i love it so much i do too i i love
air conditioning and refrigerators we
can store food i mean these are all
amazing things in it and it became
possible through fossil fuel energies
but the democrats want to take it away
because they're saying that carbon is
the problem well i think there has to be
i think there's to be a middle ground
right because you've said
we've gotten a lot from fossil fuels and
just like you were talking about you
know abortion was only became legal in
the in the 1970s it's like okay so some
things from the past are also bad right
like we also used to have slaves we also
used to not have uh polio vaccines we
also used to look like
cast members of the oregon trail um but
i think acknowledging that it's like
yeah some some stuff we use in excess uh
is hurting the environment what is that
how can we
come up with alternatives for that while
also
not going the complete
lefty route of like throw it all out you
know what i mean let it be market driven
and and here's the thing so we can't
rely on on wind turbines right now that
remember they froze in texas and now i
was in that storm by the way
i had i lived in austin for like three
weeks and i was like ah texas is great
and then suddenly you had to like
sophie's because he was like yeah oh
yeah oh that's what it was a hundred
percent i was like this isn't what
everyone's talking about it's just a
bunch of hipsters and joe rogan uh it
was wonderful and breakfast tacos uh and
then yeah within three weeks that storm
happened and you suddenly have to like i
i was like
dumping chlorine pool water into the
back of my toilet so i could like
attempt to flush it and wow none of us
had like it was totally it was crazy so
that's a failure we can't rely on that
energy it's the it's not there yet and
i'm i'm not a fan of those things i
think they're gigantic and ugly and then
we have solar panels overheating right
now they can't provide enough
electricity and we have china and other
countries moving back to coal so what do
you mean real quick we do have a big a a
bit of a breaking story that i want to
get to in a second but i want so i want
to ask one quick question before we move
on is uh
who do you think for 2024 you think i
mean obviously trump's running president
trump's running he's running so you're
you're he just hasn't said it yet well
we just talked about all the great
reasons to have him as president right
yeah i mean for me i mean foreign policy
has always been one of the biggest
issues for me that you know
we have to
the sacrifice of americans uh of the
bravest american men and women for
corporate bs
look at where we are right now
especially in the world where we are
right now we're in a dangerous place
we we are actively fighting a proxy war
with a nuclear country russia
that that is dangerous uh but just
i'm curious your thoughts on desantis
because he's the name that's popped up i
think desantis is fantastic i really do
but i would i'm a little selfish i would
love to have president trump for four
years and then i went to santos for
eight what about trump i want 12. what
about trump desantis for four years and
then the stand for eight years they
can't though right because they're from
the same state and a president and vice
president yep
president and vice president cannot be
from the same state you and your
conspiracies i know
so if he moved his residence to new
jersey
he's in new jersey right now isn't he
yeah
what if he says i'm a resident of new
jersey now then what if that's what he's
doing they said aren't they doing
construction on mar-a-lago or something
oh i don't know
what a convenience store
you know something
look on your face lock the doors lock
the doors no i'm just enjoying listening
to you guys i think we're gonna see a
lot of people run
you're gonna see um oh my goodness we've
got nikki haley probably mike pence who
else is gonna run christine christie
gnome maybe oh wow good job there's
gonna be there's gonna be a lot of
people running and then obviously on the
democrat ticket there's gonna be a lot
of people running too yeah but no one
with any
i can't wait for gavin newsom it's gonna
be so much fun oh he's the worst
do democrats like him no no right he's
awful let me tell you the dark horse
then i don't think he's running but it
would put a it would make it hard for
republicans um
but they hate them they would never do
it is joe manchin if joe manchin
think about that thanks for checking out
this clip from tim cast irl come hang
out live monday through friday at 8pm
eastern time super chat we'll even
answer some of your questions if you
want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time
you